I’m Adam Davis, writer/director of BROKEN
CEILING, a feature film I shot in just four
days in one location.
The film is about a woman who after countless
disappointments and chronic mistreatment at
her job decides to turn a routine meeting
into a life-changing confrontation.
If people would like to check it out, BROKEN
CEILING is available on iTunes, Google Play,
Vudu and is free for Amazon Prime members.
And I can be found at Adam Davis film on Twitter
and Instagram.
When I set out to write the film I had a unique
challenge.
How do I make four people stuck in a conference
room together interesting for 90 minutes?
How do I keep the tension up so that the audience
stays engaged?
I decided to incorporate a lot of narrative
twists and turns and use flashbacks to help
the audience understand how the characters
got to such a dire, dangerous situation.
If you’re constantly keeping the audience
guessing and surprising them with unexpected
moments, they’ll be along for the whole
ride.
I also wrote scenes taking place in the cubicle
farm and the boss’s office, in the restrooms,
which was able to break up the monotony of
the conference room narratively and visually.
From a production standpoint, having all of
these side locations in the office building
we shot in was a godsend.
The cast and crew could just land at the location
and everything we need was there.
Spaces for hair and make-up, restrooms people
could use, a kitchen we could base lunch and
crafty in, there was no need to travel which
was key to shooting the film in four days.
Since about 60% of the film takes place in
the conference room itself, I had to figure
out a visual style that would keep things
looking interesting as well as figuring out
the blocking to move the actors around the
room as the dynamics of the characters changed.
For the visual style I had the language of
the film change as the story progressed.
So I started with a lot of shots on sticks
and some steady handheld shots.
I did not want the camera to be noticeable
when things were just getting started.
As the story got more intense I switched to
a more handheld style, looser and intense
itself like Paul Greengrass did in the Bourne
movies or that great opening scene in JJ Abrams
MISSION IMPOSSIBLE 3.
I also put the camera physically closer to
the characters so that you really felt that
you were part of the situation.
Now for the blocking I wanted everything to
be motivated by the power dynamic in the room.
So at the beginning of the film the boss Ken
has all the power.
He’s at the head of the table lording over
the three employees.
But as each of the employees take their shot
at the throne (so to speak) the positions
around the table change.
Over time our protagonist Angela goes from
the assistant position way off to the side
unnoticeable really to slowly making her way
closer and closer to the throne.
More and more in frame of the wide shots for
example.
But of course the other two employees Tyler
and Garret engage in the power struggle as
well so their positions move and then you’re
getting this very dynamic dance motivated
by each character’s desires.
You couple that blocking with the visual style
and you have something that the audience can
really sink their teeth into.
What could have been a boring, static, one-location
story becomes meaty and thematically engaging.
What I would say is give yourself limitations
when you’re thinking about your next project
or your current project.
Box yourself into a corner because you’ll
be forced to dig deep into the material to
make it as creative and interesting as possible.
Finding the depth in the story will help keep
the cast, crew and even you really, really
motivated to bring it to life in new ways.
Again, please check out the film at BROKEN
CEILING movie [dot] com and let me know your
thoughts at Adam Davis Film on Twitter and
Instagram.